skifahren am berg herrmann
da werden manche neidisch gucken auch
wenn sie noch nie von diesem gebiet auf
den golanhöhen gehört haben seit der
annexion des koran durch israel wurde es
immer weiter ausgebaut sehnsüchtig haben
die israelis auf die öffnung letzte
woche gewartet
[Musik]
wir sind glücklich nach der langen zeit
eingesperrt zu hause ich bin studentin
und lerne seit einem jahr von daheim aus
es ist ein glück frische luft zu atmen
ski zu fahren und mit allen gemeinsam
spaß zu haben
wir treffen familie geduld auf dem
skihang vater mutter vier töchter der
strippe ist ein geschenk für vier im
april geht sie zur armee vorher wollte
sie unbedingt noch einmal ski laufen
das ist das erste mal dieses jahr weil
man wegen corona nicht ins ausland
fahren kann und ich genieße das
es ist sehr nett in israel ski zu fahren
in unserem land zwei dinge habe die
pandemie sie gelehrt sagte vier die
bedeutung von familie und demut man ist
glücklich über die kleinen dinge im
leben weil nichts mehr
selbstverständlich ist trotz corona
sollte man verstehen wie relativ alles
im leben ist und sich über das freuen
was man hat vater und mutter meera sind
geimpft die töchter nicht ins skigebiet
dürften sie wie alle hier nur mit online
anmeldung denn für alle öffnungen in
israel gilt keine freiheiten ohne
einschränkung und so braucht man hier
zwar wieder grünen pass noch corona test
aber statt wie sonst 12.000 dürfen nur
2500 auf den berg wir haben genug von
corona aber es ist etwas das uns
auferlegt wurde
wir hoffen vor allem durch den einfluss
der impfungen dass wir darauf bald als
ein stück geschichte zurückblicken
werden
doch soweit ist es noch nicht zwar
öffnet das land immer weiter
doch die pandemie hat tiefe wunden
geschlagen auch wirtschaftlich nicht nur
die skilehrer waren lange arbeitslos die
gesamte region um das neue modell chance
hat gelitten
der hermann ist der wirtschaftliche
anteil des nordens ein winter ohne den
berg heißt der gesamte norden ist tot
denn es ist nicht nur der hermann selbst
es geht um restaurants zimmer hotels
tankstellen und geschäfte
in tel aviv wird schon wieder gefeiert
es ist pure in kostüme und karneval mit
religiösen ursprung erlaubt ist das ohne
maske und abstand und für solche
menschenmengen nicht denn die zahl der
neuinfektionen bleibt hoch gerade die
jüngeren sind längst nicht durch geimpft
die über 50 jährigen dagegen schon
zweimal und das zu über 80 prozent
[Musik]
auch die ultraorthodoxen feiern purim
angeblich sind alle teilnehmer hier
geimpft oder von kogit 19 genesen ist
drohen hohe strafen durchgesetzt werden
die kaum über das buch am wochenende
wurde lediglich eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre verhängt
bevor ihm schon letztes purim hatten wir
einen gefährlichen ausbruch mit massen
infektionen wie sie sich erinnern
mussten wir einen schatten über das
ganze land verhängt
das darf sich nicht wiederholen zugleich
wächst die sorge vor corona mutationen
der flughafen ist geschlossen im prinzip
den israelis aus aller welt dürften
zurück ins land die regierung testet nun
eine elektronische am kessel zur
kontrolle der quarantäne bürgerrechte
sind entsetzt die ersten freiwilligen
scheint nicht zu stören
für uns ist das großartig so müssen wir
nicht ins quarantäne hotel sondern
können die zeit zu hause verbringen so
wie es sein soll
im land selbst werden immer weitere
bereiche geöffnet zuletzt auch alle
hotels wie die hier am toten meer
die hotels dort bilden eine so genannte
grüne insel
der zugang ist streng reglementiert und
wird an der zufahrt kontrolliert nur wer
den grünen pass als geimpfte oder
genesen auf vorweisen kann befreien
zu den hotels der grünen insel auch mit
negativen krone test die abgewiesenen
sind sauer
das ist sehr schlimm das ist nicht in
ordnung
sie teilen die bürger ein in erster und
zweiter klasse
hier ist ein öffentlicher strand ich
will gar nicht ins bett und matisse im
topf haben den grünen pass nach langer
zeit gönnen sie sich am wochenende am
toten meer und haben doch ein mulmiges
gefühl dabei der frage nach ob wir nicht
zu schnell öffnen feiern wir schon
wieder zu schnell
israel ist ein land der extreme entweder
schwarz oder weiß
wir haben nach dem ersten lockdown
gefeiert und nach dem zweiten wir sind
ein bisschen skeptisch
auch das restaurant im hotel ist
geöffnet vom personal wird erwartet dass
sie sich impfen lässt regelmäßige corona
tests sollen vertrauen schaffen hier
passiert oft traut der sache nicht ganz
und bleibt lieber für sich das gefühl
von normalität mag sich irgendwie nicht
einstellen
die tatsache dass alle masken tragen ist
schon bizarr komisch auch wieder mit
anderen menschen zusammen zu sein wir
sind nicht mehr daran gewöhnt
wir nutzen auch nicht alle angebote hier
im hotel das paar und andere sachen da
schreckt uns noch
andere machen sich da weniger sorgen die
chefs sind lieber draußen und machen
sich da so ihre gedanken über die welt
und krone
das virus habe die gesellschaft
gespalten vor allem die missachtung der
chor ohne regeln durch ultraorthodoxe
das hat uns in großem maße polarisiert
ich sehe das als großes versagen unserer
führung die deren fehlverhalten
weitgehend toleriert hat
corona auch die zeit der verpassten
chancen
das wäre eine gelegenheit gewesen unsere
nachbarn die hände zu reichen den
palästinensern der hamas anstatt sie
wegzustoßen das ist eine große verpasste
politische gelegenheit zu sagen hört man
leute der ware krieg findet nicht
zwischen uns statt sondern zwischen uns
und dem virus die korona pandemie hat
viele probleme nur verdeckt verschwunden
sind die deshalb nicht